on the topic of uh
like discovery of evidence of alien
civilizations which is something you
touch on in your book
what that idea would do to
societies to the human psyche
and in general do you think and you talk
about the
uh i still have trouble pronouncing but
wager right wha what do you think
is can you explain it and what do you
think in general is the
effect that such knowledge might have on
human civilization
right so pascal had this wager about god
and by the way there are interesting
connections between theology
and the search for extraterrestrial life
you know it's possible that
you know we were planted on this planet
by another civilization yes you know we
attribute
to god powers that are that belong
really to technological civilization
but putting that aside uh pascal
basically said
you know let's the two possibilities
either god exists or not
right and if god exists
you know the consequences are quite
significant
and therefore you know we should we
should consider that possibility
differently than equal weight to both
possibilities
and i suggest that we do the same with
omuamua or
other technological signatures that we
keep in mind the consequences
and therefore pay more attention to that
possibility now
some people say extraordinary claims
require
extraordinary evidence my point is that
the term extraordinary
is really subjective you know for one
person
a black hole is extraordinary for
another you know it's just a consequence
of einstein's theory of gravity
yeah it's nothing extraordinary the same
about the type of dark matter
anything so we should leave the
extraordinary
part of that sentence just keep
evidence okay so let's be guided by
evidence
and even even if we have extraordinary
claims you know let's not
dismiss them because the evidence is not
extraordinary enough because
if we have an image of something and it
looks really strange and we say oh the
image is not sufficiently
sharp therefore we should not even pay
attention to this image or not even
consider
i think that's a mistake yes what we
should do is say
look there is some evidence for
something unusual let's try
and build instruments that will give us
a better image
and if you just dismiss extraordinary
claims
because the you consider them
extraordinary you avoid
discovering things that you haven't
expected and so
i believe that along the history of
astronomy there are many missed
opportunities
and i speak about astronomy but i'm sure
in other fields it's also true i mean
this is
my expertise for example you know the
astrophysical journal which is the main
primary publication in astrophysics
uh if you go you go beyond before the
1980s there are images that were posted
in the astrophysical journal
of giant arcs you know arcs of light
surrounding clusters of galaxies
and you know you can find it in printed
versions of the astrophysical genome
people just ignore
they put the image they see the arc they
say
who knows what it is and just ignore it
and then
in the 1980s the subject of
gravitational lensing became popular
and the idea is that you can deflect
light
by the force of gravity and
then you can put the source behind the
cluster of galaxies and then you will
get these arcs
and actually einstein predicted it uh in
1940 and
you know so these things were expected
but
people just had them in the images
didn't pay attention so i'm sure there
are lost opportunities sometimes you
even in existing data you have things
that are unusual and
exceptional and are not being addressed
you